chantal hébert paul journet michel david
de bonsoir
hier soir c'est la conférence de presse
du premier ministre de l'alberta donc
qui il fut pris dans maison je m'excuse
il faut changer stratégie passeport
vaccinale au plus vite nous hôpitaux
commencent à déborder je fais écouter un
petit extrait de monsieur canet et des
répercussions que ça a eu sur la
campagne fédérale aujourd'hui
info
c'est à briser le coeur et nous allons
comme gouvernement être là pour les
albertains mais comme le premier
ministre ni l'a avoué hier soir
son approche était erroné je vais
travailler avec les provinces au québec
en alberta dans notre lutte collective
contre la corvette 19 c'était totalement
irresponsable dû déclencher une élection
en pleine d'une pandémie c'est
clairement une manque de leadership en
alberta du pardon monsieur kenny et on
doit le blâmer
alors test de leadership dit monsieur
trudeau en même temps bon monsieur
autour à une longue période de questions
difficiles aujourd'hui parce que les
journalistes ont posé plusieurs fois la
même question qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la gestion me chicaner mais néanmoins
salue quand même permet de rappeler
qu'il ya une campagne électorale en
pleine pandémie qu'est-ce que vous
comment vous pensez que ça va répercuter
va se répercuter dans la campagne
chantal
le problème c'est que c'est pas parce
qu'il me campagne électorale que
monsieur tanner cependant un certain
nombre de semaines donc qui a déclaré au
début de l'été que l'alberta n'aurait
pas un été à l'est trudeau mais un vrai
était le meilleur hôte vie pour
l'alberta j'ai cinq années c'est un
personnage central dans le mouvement
conservateur au canada en même temps on
a vu le premier ministre conservateur du
nouveau brunswick sera lié au passeport
vaccinale aujourd'hui c'est celui de la
saskatchewan qui avait lui aussi
juridique jamais faire ça je pense que
si la situation n'était pas devenue
intenable en alberta pour jesse une
canne et en saskatchewan pour scott
moore sur le front de la pandémie il
aurait préféré attendre à mardi et
arnaud tout aurait été mieux pour sa
pole
mais c'est ce que m dos et c'est de
faire c'est à dire que c'est pourtant
une décision d'une mauvaise gestion de
messieurs kenny est môme est ce une
mauvaise gestion conservatrice
évidemment pour associer sa à son rival
et puis ici et rino tout l'été à l'aise
sur ce terrain il aurait pas essayer de
mettre fin à sa conférence de presse
mais c'est extrêmement embarrassant pour
l'alberta et la saskatchewan écouter en
juin dernier il était entré une rires
des médias et de rire des experts en dix
ans les journalistes de vente de la peur
en échange de clics c'est du journalisme
de sensationnalisme
on dirait que vous voulez que la
pandémie continue mais on n'est plus là
alors qui est des gens sérieux qui les
mettait en garde est là aujourd'hui il
roule depuis hier et aux coulées en
disant écoutez il faut être gentil il
faut prendre soin les uns des autres
mais c'est pas du tout la proches qu'ils
avaient donc c'est vraiment un échec
pour ses premiers cela puis aussi pour
le style de politique le rappeur
abrasives polarisantes qui est pas du
tout la bonne pour faire face à une
pandémie et eau comment ça commence à se
traduit pour monsieur au tour michel
david écoutez on a vu ainsi aux tôles
prend tous les moyens pour éviter de
parler de monsieur canet c'est bien
évident que pour lui c'est pas une
nouvelle tout ça c'est la marque
conservatrice qui est qui et qui est
terminée avec toute cette histoire leur
maintenant la question c'est de savoir à
qui j'ai vraiment ça va profiter est-ce
que c'est monsieur trudeau tout va en
profiter chez npd
c'est pas clair dans mon esprit que
monsieur trudeau qui a aucun député
actuellement en alberta moi je suis
assez loin du terrain la bonne mais il
se peut très bien le qui travaillent
pour quelqu'un d'autre le dans ces
derniers jours deux ans en prenant mais
ce nouvel qui répercutait à toronto
aussi beaucoup en ontario a tout à fait
écoutez je ne peux pas je prendrais de
vous expliquer que c'est une bonne chose
pour monsieur autour bien au contraire
et c'est mais depuis le début de la
pandémie je pense que monsieur o toole
quand il s'agit de savoir lequel sera
mieux à même de gérer la pandémie
je pense que dans l'esprit de beaucoup
de gens c'est pas monsieur automne très
nettement et ça ça ne fait que renforcer
l'impression que les conservateurs qui
aurait peut-être été un choix
plus plus intéressant après la pandémie
pour une reprise économique et cetera
pour ce qui est de la gestion de la
pandémie c'est clairement podium donc
chantelle est ce que pour monsieur
trudeau selon vous c'est un gain c'est
sûr que l'on parle de choses pas drôle
en alberta mais sur le chemin de la
campagne ce que c'est un gain
aujourd'hui pour monsieur trudeau ce que
c'est positif pour lui
oui c'est possible pour lui
stratégiquement c'est possible pour lui
pas nécessairement parce que des tonnes
de gens éveillés
dos mais plutôt parce que il ya une
tonne de gens et c'est la raison pour
laquelle monsieur au tour de guet voulu
que ça attentes si possible mais anton
de gens en alberta en saskatchewan et
ailleurs qui vont dire moi je m'en vais
voter pour maxime bernier et ces gens là
qui sont contre les mesures sanitaires
et qui ont cru sur parole parce que
c'est pas juste pour le plaisir que j'ai
une cane et scott nous disait jamais on
va faire ça c'est parce qu'une grande
partie de leur base en son temps ce sont
des conservateurs sont totalement
opposés réfractaires aux mesures
sanitaires ces gens là une nouvelle
raison lundi d'aller voter pour maxime
bernier ce sont majoritairement des
électeurs conservateurs ils maxime
bernier savions pas pris de temps il ya
eu un tweet sur ma tâche pression
l'homme il a accusé monsieur canidé est
un des sports depuis lundi ça y est vous
entrez dans le bal de jambon dont la
vienne la déclarer la guerre à notre
charte des droits et libertés lui
carburateur bernier et pau lons on l'a
vu il manque quand même dans les temps
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui
veulent entendre ça oui parce que pour
monter dans les sondages maxime bernier
si vous lui donnez deux ou trois points
de pourcentage de plus une croissance
significative alors que pour les autres
le ça ça reste assez marginale l'on voit
son plafond ils veulent l'atteindre vite
parce que je comprends qu'il dit que
c'est liberticide ce qui se passe en
alberta mais les gens qui s'intéressent
au moins un petit peu à la réalité
constate qu'on est rendu à parler de
délestage en alberta carrément pour des
opérations médicales des gens qui
pourront pas être soigné donc les gens
qui étaient déjà furieux contre les
mesures sanitaires logiquement si les
mesures se resserre ils seront encore
plus furieux est encore plus motivé
peut-être une légère croissance mais
parmi un bassin de militants qui somme
toute demeure assez restreint mais bon
on verra si ça peut permettre à des
candidats
ça peut nuire à des candidats
conservateurs permettre à nos deux héros
de se faufiler en alberton est
très bien monsieur après monsieur
chrétien je me l'ont dit hier on va
coûter un petit extrait c'est à hartford
dans bon missisquoi n'écoute monsieur
moreau
je suis souche irlandaise et renault si
je suis devenu avocat et un aussi à
mérida aps l solidaire
a indiqué mme aubry solberg
je suis devenu cher super six et renault
si je suis devenu leader de l'opposition
officielle et arnaud si je suis devenu
premier ministre du canada
et la semaine prochaine
j'ai été très content de pouvoir
travailler à côté de monsieur bonjour ni
quand venait le temps de lutter pour le
canada condamne notre offre sur l'alena
sur les sanctions en acier en aluminium
on était on faisait partie de la même
équipe
je rappelais par contre que monsieur
retour n'était pas d'accord ni avec
monsieur mongeau ni ni avec mon approche
monsieur otto comme monsieur harper
voulait capituler face aux américains
je n'ai pas l'intention unis sollicité
ni même appelé bon gilles n'a pas besoin
d'être sûre si d'une part parce que il
connaît assez peu et ça me fait bien
plaisir la notion de silence il est dans
les milieux très régulièrement dont le
pack modem charpy on demandera pas
monsieur bouchard non plus
ouais gilles qui sera
qui connaît assez la notion de style
ainsi très comique d'un simple
expression jeu blanc ah oui
papa qui dit à lu ces mouchards pensez
vous une seule seconde si lucien
bouchard disait j'ai le goût de faire
une sortie en appelant la nation
québécoise à voter massivement pour le
bloc que l'heure est grave pensez vous
vraiment que monsieur blanchet s'en
priverait
si l'appel poste parce qu'il a
l'impression que son appel ne sera pas
retourner ou que la réponse doit être un
genre de non poli bon bah journée michel
david est ce que ça a un impact au
québec ailleurs comment vous avez vu ça
oui je pense qu'au québec monsieur
mulroney d'abord est encore très
populaire et monsieur mulroney le
incarne la tentative de réconciliation
avec le québec et monsieur otto il se
veut lui aussi ouvert aux demandes du
québec de façon générale au québec c'est
tout à fait positif ça aussi et là ça
peut poser des problèmes à la base
conservatrice en os ça cautionne le
recentrage
du de monsieur autour et ça il ya des
gens qui de toute évidence et ne me font
pas ça alors il est pas évident que ce
qu'ils gagnent au québec il en perdra
pas un peu ailleurs mais je suis
convaincu que monsieur otto laisser
stratèges ont tous bien évaluer sa fille
qui sont aussi bons au total ça va être
payant mais un cocon à tout ça que ce
soit monsieur m'a donné que ce soit
monsieur chrétien ou monsieur obama moi
je pense pas que ça va avoir des effets
très significatif sur les électeurs dans
le cas d'obama quand c'est une deuxième
fois sa jamais la même même effet qu'une
première fois un champ tels que je vais
penser de l'assurance mais sûrement la
journée sur les lecteurs us croit pas
que c'est un grand impact chaud et là je
fais une différence entre jean chrétien
et
jean chrétien quand on sort à ce moment
ci de la campagne se donne du corps à
l'ouvragé aux militants libéraux aux
gens qui travaillent pour faire sortir
le vote il n'y a pas là dessus un
clivage à l'intérieur du parti libéral
aujourd'hui quand on sort monsieur ma
journée c'est à peu près le contraire la
base militante de ce parti conservateur
qui n'est pas le 6 et une base militante
qui se reconnaît et d'ailleurs et non
tout le passé toute sa campagne au
leadership à dire moi je suis la
personne qui va empêcher une partie de
retomber entre les mains de ce genre de
personne n'a en en choisissant plutôt
qui te remets qui le clan marronner
derrière public et gens vrais bleus
avaient dit
et pensé couleur là je ne suis pas cette
personne là c'était un peu le choc et
pas seulement dans l'ouest à
l'extérieur à l'ouest du québec et à
l'ontario en chemin de militants qui
disaient oh de quoi on parle et ce qui
est un peu gênant on vient de sortir
deux anciens premiers ministres jean
chrétien et monsieur ma journée
et c'était maintenant harper pendant ce
temps les dans son sous-sol mahdi un
conservateur en train de regarder des
reprises de là
si on s'en
sont les néo démocrates qui vont prendre
part et qui vont rallier libéraux et sa
dernière chose les doutes semble qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens je vous dirais que
si monsieur autour l'épaule élu premier
ministre lundi et qu'il ne réussit pas
demeurer chef cette semaine des
événements de cette semaine y compris
braillon de marne et vont avoir jouer là
dedans parce que les gens qui vont
décider ça c'est pas des partisans de
brian mulroney
vous avez l après j'ai fait une table
éditoriale et monsieur o'toole et je
pense que j'ai fait un article vous avez
cité charlebois tout et quartier
[Musique]
il a voulu recentrer je pense qu'il est
en train de le faire ce parti
conservateur mais ou au prix de
certaines contorsions parfois mais oui
c'est à dire qu'il y ait des
contradictions entre les positions
monsieur autour défendent est dans la
course à la direction et celle qui le
défend aujourd'hui et aussi on voit que
son programme
c'est comme on dit qui il fait beaucoup
à défaut de faire des volte-face qui
fait beaucoup d'ajustements on a
l'impression qu'ils naviguent à vue et
puis qu'en fonction des sondages où la
controverse du jour ils veulent la juste
et faire des petites notes en bas de
page comme il l'a fait avec les armes à
feu
mon défaut les changements sont moins
significatif qu'on le prétend mais en
effet il est dans de perpétuels
contorsions pour essayer à la fois de
plaire à sa base et puis de rallier les
gens qui sont plus proches du centre
droit cela dit le quand même réussi en
partie quand on regarde son programme
c'est très différent du programme de
monsieur harper mais pour revenir à ce
qu'on disait sur sur stephen harper il
est déjà dans la campagne parce que
justin trudeau part de lui à chaque jour
au risque de frôler la caricature puis
de vouloir de faire la campagne qu'il
faisait en 2015 mais on voit que quand
même des différences entre la plateforme
de monsieur o'toole et celle de monsieur
patrice des centres âge là c'est
toujours délicat lors on voit auto le
qui risque d'en perdre souvenez-vous de
temps mort qui est aussi délicat à
gauche qu'à droite monsieur mulcair en
2015 a essayé de se recentrer son parti
est
loin d'être eu d'eau est exactement est
d'abord ça lui a pas payé l'élection qui
on lui a vite montré la porte après
l'élection oui et devinez canada québec
je sais pas si on peut parler d'un autre
sans se rapprocher de l'île nationaliste
c'est très difficile en ce moment ouais
ok je fais un petit crochet je vais vous
entendre on est en pleine crise des
infirmières
monsieur legault dit faut trouver de
l'argent va trouver de l'argent pour les
faire revenus etc on ferme des hôpitaux
et ce matin on dit dans la définition de
work conférence de presse on appelle sur
ce sujet étonnement on est connu
je n'ai aucune idée de ce que françois
legault veut dire d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé
ça révélateur que quand vous les
journalistes avaient demandé à son
équipe et au ministre qui entourent
françois legault mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire le mot la personne n'a été
capable de vous répondre c'est une
étiquette qui circulent dans l'immédiat
et moi je comprends pas que france hurle
vous venez
pour moi c'est un gros que c'est
quelqu'un qui veut nous faire sentir
capable de défendre la nation québécoise
de défendre ses valeurs comme on le fait
avec la loi 21 de défendre nos
compétences un wok c'est quelqu'un qui
voit de la discrimination partout
c'est un débat intéressant ce que le
mouvement politiquement bien ce que
c'était j'ai envie de le moment ce matin
d'en parler de ça mais quand ça va mal
d'un sur un sujet on a toujours intérêt
à parler d'autre chose mais tout le
monde comprend que c'est pas tout à fait
le temps d'avoir des débats sociologique
sur le concept de web mais au delà des
péripéties puis du problème actuel dans
le système de santé je pense que
monsieur legault commence quand même à
préparer la prochaine élection
monsieur legault la livre il va il va
avoir beaucoup beaucoup d'identité dans
son discours du 6 la campagne électorale
et pendant la campagne électorale et là
il s'est trouvé un
un bon ennemi il monsieur y est parfait
lui c'est l'ancien carré rouge les
casseroles tout ce que vous voulez alors
monsieur legault va dire écoutez c'est à
ce que c'est ça que vous voulez ou si
vous voulez à québec fier est bon alors
il n'y avait pas une intention
simplement sortir d'un sujet du sel
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils voient ça à
plus long terme en inde ou du bois qui
en rient en envoyant une photo avec une
casserole wac pas un petit mot là dessus
mais c'est un cadeau aussi pour québec
solidaire qui enfin le statut de
principal opposant de monsieur legault
donc ça leur donne de la crédibilité
mais bon j'ai souri un peu en attendant
la définition de monsieur lebon du
ternois où c'est la définition la plus
locale que j'ai jamais entendu de ma
ville je pense que ça existait le terme
existait bien avant que monsieur leveaux
en prennent connaissance et ça ne
concernait pas la nation québécoise se
le dise après désignées les gens qui ont
un certain sentiment de supériorité
morale ou certains dérapages liés à la
gauche identitaire n'oublions pas que
barack obama lui même avait dénoncé tous
sommes par contre on n'est plus crédible
quand on dénonce les dérives de cette
culture le cas on est au camp on ce
combat les injustices et les racismes
donc pour être bien crédit pour
critiquer loi ou qui les lie wha kang
email il faut il faut combattre la 6e
puis monsieur le mans où il ya oui ou
devrait parler du problème initial au
lieu de parler de délais possibles pour
essayer de régler le problème très bien
chantal conclusion êtes vous la chambre
est encore avec nous chantant je viens
de revenir et j'ai manqué une partie de
la réponse mais je vais vous dire que
j'espère que les appels à la nation
contre les oies que vont avoir plus de
succès que les appels à la nation a
préféré les conservateurs ou libéraux et
d'écoles merci beaucoup à vous trois on
se revoit bientôt on se revoit bientôt
après la soirée électorale chantal paul
et michel merci à très bien merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne i see her dit